cinéma maintenant avec le retour donc de
la révélation du phénomène de cette
année 2001 audrey tautou merci d'être
avec nous vous tenait le premier rôle
dans dieu est grand je suis tout petit
un film de pascale bailly on va en voir
un extrait on va aussi rappeler que vous
avez enthousiasmé le public français
avec bien sûr le fabuleux destin
d'amélie poulain poulain fardeau grande
surprise du box office
on y revient d'abord en images
marie-josée jouant claude barny si dieu
est grand elle n'est pas si petit 1
mètre 63
auréolé par son fabuleux destin amélie
pardon audrey tautou et dans le film de
pascal balli en quête de spiritualité on
qui peut exister barack obama tu fais ça
m'a affecté au fonds pour les beaux yeux
d'edouard baer ssmm au judaïsme
l'occasion de la découvrir ici dans son
premier grand rôle le film a été tourné
en 1998 à 19 ans audrey savait déjà
comment aborder la vie
c'est en l'an 2000 que commence le conte
de fées vénus beauté lui offre son
premier césar c'est ma vie que je suis
en train de vivre là mais celle qui
chamboule sa vie c'est elle amélie une
jeune fille qui veut réparer la vie des
autres - vous risquez pas d'être un
légume puisque même un artichaut a du
coeur
deuxième film au box office derrière la
vérité si je mens 2 7 millions et demi
de spectateurs sous son charme comme
edouard baer son partenaire de dieu est
grand
ces deux là étaient faits pour jouer
ensemble je la regarde on l'écouté on
ensuite on se laisser monter et on se
dit que si on écoute bien qu'on y la
regarde bien et qu'on lui parle pas est
mal non plus parce que là c'est moins
d'intensité que ça fait rayonner ceux
qui l'approchent
et puis juste pour vaudrait un petit
conseil d'ami mais bientôt mois sur la
table répondre aux questions ne font pas
en l'armé secrète patrie j'ai fait un
peu de tout ça quand même la source et
de l'émotion à les négociants du
spectacle on avoir un comment vous
comporter on a tendance toujours des
taux tout après les films à confondre un
peu les acteurs et le personnage là on a
quand même une excuse et est ce que vous
même vous ne vous êtes pas pris de temps
en temps pour amélie poulain ah non pas
du tout cheptel kim ki moon site le
moins frisquet ce jeu me et les gens les
gens quand ils vous rencontrez pense pas
que vous êtes la bonne fée qui amène le
bonheur non non non sa page ils ont de
la sympathie parce que j'ai pas jouer
quelqu'un de méchant mais non je crois
qu'il ya pas deux ils font la différence
ision et j'élève d'admiration vous en
avez reçu beaucoup
bah j'en ai reçu quelques unes mais
c'était pas forcément des lettres qui
mettait que dessiner c'était des lettres
parce que c'était des gens qui avaient
aimé le film et qui par mme bien
remercier aussi jean pierre jeunet de
d'avoir de leur avoir fait passer deux
heures de bonheur en fait vous avez
réalisé que quelque chose qu'elle est un
peu au delà du cinéma quand même dans le
succès de ce film
ah bah oui parce que c'est vrai que ça a
pris tellement d'importance a été c'est
vrai un phénomène et c'est vrai que même
dans l'actualité fin dans la façon
d'annoncer les titres c'est vrai qu'on a
souvent utilisé le fabuleux destin de
feu y avait des petites choses comme ça
qu'ils aient que vont c'est resté dans
les esprits mais maintenant tout pas ça
c'est un peu derrière quand même on va
rappeler les chiffres vous les
connaissez le fabuleux destin d'amélie
poulain c'est le deuxième film en nombre
d'entrées de cette année 2001 juste
derrière la vérité si je mens avant le
placard avant la production disney
dinosaures avant aussi le pacte des
loups alors vous étiez connu déjà avant
là vous êtes quand même devenu une
vedette votre vie a changé
ben un petit peu changé parce que c'est
vrai que maintenant dans la rue je passe
moins inaperçu mais voilà que sinon j'ai
plus de liberté par rapport à mes choix
professionnels mais sinon et on vous
propose beaucoup de choses suffisamment
et des rôles dans le même genre ah non
pas du tout là vraiment j'ai plutôt de
la chance mais pour l'instant vraiment
on n'a pas donné des sous amélie a joué
pas du tout mais je crois que c'était un
film quand même tellement à part que je
crois qu'on peut pas vraiment avoir
envie de refaire la même chose alors ce
film-là du est grand je suis tout petit
c'est un film qui a pour toile de fond
la religion c'est un film sur la
religion ou c'est simplement le prétexte
pour rire un peu parlé de la relation de
couple et bonne comédie je crois que
c'est un peu après texte lui la religion
est elle et elle est présente mais elle
est aussi présente par le folklore et
par la tradition je crois que c'est
surtout le prétexte pour raconter
l'histoire de cette fille qui kissir
tout simplement sa place et voilà et
c'est aussi un prétexte pour raconter
cette histoire de coupe ou s'il n'y
avait pas de problème si elle ait pas de
conflit il y aurait pas d'histoire et
leurs rapports seraient moins
intéressant et moins drôle c'est sûr est
ce que ce film serait sortie s'il n'y
avait pas eu le succès d'amélie poulain
ah bah oui bien sûr parce qu'elle est
retournée à 20 mais même il devait
sortir juste avant le film
et puis on s'est dit que c'était dommage
bas de qui passe à la trappe parce que
il ya une telle attente par rapport aux
films de jeunes et que du coup on s'est
dit qu'on allait pas en parler qui
valait mieux profiter de d'amélie pour
justement lui donner toutes ses chances
merci beaucoup devraient tous d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation et puis bonne
chance pour ce film